il est devenu roi de la mort de sa mère
mais cette cérémonie qui n'avait pas eu
lieu depuis 70 ans est venu ajouter un
peu de fanfares et de décorum à son
accession 30 du royaume uni charles iii
n'était pas présent au moment où ces
paroles ont d'abord été prononcé en
présence de membres de la famille royale
et de six anciens premiers ministres
toujours en vie
or selon
l'ofas
a profité de la cérémonie pour rendre un
hommage bien senti à sa mère elizabeth 2
mais c'était surtout le moment pour lui
d'assumer ses responsabilités
publiquement pour la première fois un
diplôme je suis profondément conscient
de ce grand héritage des devoirs et des
lourds de responsabilité de la
souveraineté qui me sont désormais
transmises lundi le roi joue meneur
prost mais
dans la cour extérieure du palais de st
james plusieurs centaines de membres du
public ont pu se tailler une place pour
assister à une page d'histoire pop up
gavin street était aux premières loges
c'est une chose que le titre soit
automatiquement remis au roi ziti mais
c'est la formalité qui est importante et
j'adore les cérémonies c'était quelque
chose d'être témoin de ça j'en ai eu des
frissons
à 19 ans willem samuel est tout aussi
attachée à la monarchie à ce qu'elle
représente et à ses rituels
bien sûr plus important par le passé dit
il avant les réseaux sociaux et que tout
le monde le sache tout instantanément et
de les voir encore aujourd'hui c'est
important pour notre héritage et pour
maintenir en vie les idées qui sous tend
notre pays
il fallait jouer du coude pour entrevoir
le roi charles qui est ensuite rentré en
voiture au palais de buckingham à
quelques centaines de mètres du palais
saint james
sarah gray a même réussi à se faire une
photo un peu flou mais qui fait toute sa
joie
nous avons vu le roi d'angleterre
c'était génial il saluait dit elle nous
avons entendu deux heures et demie mais
ça valait le coup quels souvenirs
c'est maintenant aux autres pays du
royaume de se retrouver en présence de
charles iii le roi doit se rendre au
cours des prochains jours en irlande du
nord au pays de galles et en écosse
avant de revenir ici à londres pour la
suite des cérémonies funéraires
l'accès aux grilles du palais de
buckingham était impossible en après
midi pour la plus grande déception de
tous ceux qui continuent booker mains de
venir offrir leur sympathie à la famille
royale bousculade escalade leurs
tentatives 8 est vaine
au milieu du chaos piteux meuse rédige
calmement une note qu'il peut laisser
pour la reine difficile pour lui de
trouver comment exprimer toute sa
reconnaissance pour ce qu'il conçoit
comme une vie de sacrifice et
d'abnégation
j'ai attendu au dernier moment dit il je
suis sur le point de déposer mes fleurs
et j'écris encore c'est difficile de lui
exprimer adéquatement ma gratitude
c'est finalement aux mots de shakespeare
dans le roi lear qu'il s'en remet pour
dire adieu à la reine
les dernières paroles de la pièce sont
d'un des survivants dit il il nous faut
subir le fardeau de cette triste époque
dire ce que nous ressentons et non ce
que nous devrions dire les plus vieux ou
le plus souffert ou qui sommes jeunes
nous ne verrons jamais tant de choses à
nous vivrons jamais si longtemps nos
élèves sont longues c'est aussi
shakespeare qui écrivait que les jeunes
s'élève quand les vieux tombe pas si
jeune finalement né charles iii s'est
bien élevée sur le trône aujourd'hui ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada l'ombre